[Music]
in cash me outside news catch me outside
[ __ ] this
submitted by Michael juice dude I know a
girl that that squeeze green slime out
her no I'm not even kidding you serene
why is she okay I shouldn't Annie I
don't know I was like put it away
this happened is this nice when he shows
up no she's like let me show you
something that I never showed Eddie but
he does she could do it all the time
yeah that's yeah that's yeah is she cute
what you guys sucking on her titties you
want he has a questionable question hmm
can I reserve half the pie for after
which no one knows what the [ __ ] we
having I made that we made this pipe
slice Ryan got and I was like that's not
fair
how's the pie a pie you can have much as
you want
well did you have a nice kitty I know
something about that [ __ ] up
I shouldn't you know what I mean like I
don't know how to judge teas well that's
right cuz you don't see what guys see ya
at all that's really fun dust is what
you're sucking on it Katie yeah yeah
yeah yeah and how much like a lot a
little bit a little bit a drop but even
a little bits like what is that I don't
know she didn't see a doctor about it
because she didn't have health insurance
or anything so I don't go over this line
I mean I'm sure like in her young 20 is
gross yeah and this was a while ago so
no she never gave bray like she never
breastfed okay I forgot to try her titty
milk but the second time around it's
gonna happen oh you said you were gonna
try the titty milk I know but I was just
so focused on like that why did why did
that feel like a thread a little bit no
cuz I didn't get it do it the first time
but the second time is it
first time so so like stuck and focus on
like fatherhood for the first time oh
you [ __ ] out so I would see ya her and
Tyga and I'm also beautiful and it's
just like that whole experience and I
forgot about myself
mm-hmm and so now I'm like man do you
have the same experience that TIFF had
with the hydro focus in the shower yeah
uh it wasn't that crazy like you're
right it was like like a sprinkle he
would cry oh my god
so it is true the baby crying activates
it I thought the [ __ ] tingly omona
shower cuz that's what they would that's
what I saw that was hot a cooler yeah
cuz it would be high and like oh this is
it even the article it's not but it's
okay I ain't talking about I just
remembered that was like me what was
article oh yeah the steady man will
juice girl no I was submitted by nipple
Jones
oh no but I wanted to ask after you stop
giving her Tyco Christmas breastfeeding
did after the whole thing you made
complicated I did would you stop like
when he suck your titties in like
something would come out cuz Casey said
and this is four years after I was
breastfeeding or three years because my
breast but for you I know every time you
say this story I don't want to hear I
think you would like it tastes a little
like something and I'm like what
I haven't had milk in there for years I
don't know you know what I took a bath
with my mom when I was little and then
she squeezed my nipple and I squeezed
her nipple back and milk came out
I remember I was like how old are you
yeah seven or something
we were in the tub she was watching me
and it she was like me Pete Pete Pete
and then she would go like me and then
she squeezed my nipples like ow
and I said I squeezed her back and then
I squeezed it hard and she was like oh I
didn't milk came out like a little bit
oh [ __ ] yeah isn't that crazy how the
human mind works
you don't realize all these men until
there's a trigger for it yeah I love
that [ __ ] where you fight where you
don't get all these stories and then
there's a trip oh [ __ ] no how many
[ __ ] terabytes of memories we got but
you know like bathing together for us is
bonding yeah so then it's like we have
we have talk time we take a bath and
then like you know like I just shot my
mom all the time I wonder because I
breastfed for a whole year like maybe
just like you lasted longer because of
you were only a few months right I don't
know he doesn't say it it still happens
anyway Oh bad Bobby Daniel sorry bad
Bobby looks like Bobby bad baby Daniel
Danielle Abrego leach thousand dollar
makeup brand deal Wow
though that little [ __ ] keeps winning
and winning dude she's only 15 she's got
almost she's a millionaire the haters if
you'll money and myself she's made a
million dollars in one brand deal yeah I
don't know happy she is though oh she
look happy as [ __ ] yeah
her teeth doesn't look happy people she
just got him fixed I saw this article 40
on all veneer the teeth always looked
like they were fighting each other
mmm I didn't notice her teeth and then
now that I saw that thing although her
to mess up now they don't even need
teeth if you got a million dollar can we
see her more than that oh let me find
that article again got a seat repair
that this girl who's a little [ __ ]
like blew up but everyone wants a
villain so they keep the villains alive
that way that's how the Kardashians won
yeah also - I will say this I've
listened to her music [ __ ] got some
flow she can't she's not a lyricist but
she got some [ __ ] flows she
understands that's tough I was a little
shocked I was like oh [ __ ] talk about
catch me outside okay I was thinking
about the other girl whoa whoa Vicki all
the guns girl teeth is all for teeth
yeah hurt either or teeth spot - yeah
but then there was nothing wrong with
them before look I probably didn't even
pay forty thousand and it was probably
sponsored all the she she's like oh my
god is that her yeah that's her
oh yeah she does not look 15 looks like
[ __ ] Tola ariana grande 26 there's no
does she turn black well huh she looks
like a black girl Oh with the drawstring
ponytail and slicked back hair yeah see
what you saying yeah she went from all
from a white girl to a black girl yeah
well she's killing it because she got
that deal and they're saying that that's
a one-year deal that's really six-month
deal and it's with copycat beauty which
I've never heard know somebody she is
she's still very popular and so she's
saying that she's gonna be showing the
makeup and like her music videos and
just you know on her Instagram and stuff
and they're saying that that will that
might lead to a longer contract where
she will come out with her own makeup
line I wonder what the [ __ ] that meeting
was like to is like excuse me miss bad
baby if you do this isn't this you get a
million dollars out this hand like that
meeting like oh god man what says what
she said copycat Beauty can't or can't
do her accent Kappa Kappa Beauty came
with the bag and the great makeup at
great prices for my fans so it was a
no-brainer
what if she doesn't even talk like that
like she's in the business meeting like
well I have to speak to my lawyer
hood and afterwards when they get on
camera y'all got to make out like oh
yeah I got a makeup line it's amazing
though I'm so happy for you you little
[ __ ] bag is it is she cool with their
mom I mean they're like BFFs of course
they're BFFs now cuz she's making money
momager
she's momager I like to believe that
they have a shitty life are you sure no
no I feel like they're arguing every day
and it got problems and even more
problems she's 15 of course there are
you know this [ __ ] is hormonal she's
trying to figure herself a most 15
year-olds arguing what their long yeah
but they're probably arguing in a room
with perfect AC on silk pillows with the
[ __ ] hundred inch screen TV important
thing AC was the number one like rich
thinking year because I like the
ventilation I like I like feeling
movement in the room that's the sad part
about me as a human being it's like when
I see this I'm like I'm hoping in 10
years she's gonna be on et where she
talks about the men she met that punched
her in her face Wow oh oh
see God is fair what he's David know
what she do tonight House you hurt you
I'm joking hater I'm jealous I am
behavior that fuels her face sometimes
God punishing you because like you have
a lot of bad luck a lot of punch I was a
murderer in my past life that's
different I see what I'm saying is if
you guys don't feel that way when you
see somebody who has all this dope [ __ ]
in their piece of [ __ ] then you hear bad
news about them he goes it makes sense
now yeah that's all I'm saying that's
all I'm saying all I'm saying is you
know just probably that my dog that
bites her they always go broke mm-hmm
all I'm saying is poor people that win
the lotto they always go broke because
they don't know how to manage their
money maybe your mighty meds grow so
hopefully she like knows how to manage
it is what I'm saying because money is
not happiness and we all know this
yeah but they think you could buy it
sometimes we all know this it's not
happiness but the root of you very
comfortably about a million dollars is
because we have friends and family that
are not dysfunctional and it's it's a
good time because then after that you
could use it for other things now you
can have a grow and
imagine if you're in a toxic [ __ ] up
family and then you get that million
dollars gonna [ __ ] it up even more and
in this situation is that grandpa so
it's all guys like I already have a
brain of one this will probably
high-five
sometimes the [ __ ] comes out of your
brain and it's so good that you got a
[ __ ] yep me too but the way you said
punched in her face is like saying I
used a bad example what I meant was that
some somebody died in her life what do
you say no you're suck believe it I
think there's karma [ __ ] works itself
out I don't think someone that like
built their career off of disrespecting
their mom is gonna last long I think
when you look at it from a daily slice
of life nothing but good things
happening but who knows in five years
she could be bankrupt in ten years she
could be missing or she can be like
someone like [ __ ] Kim Kardashian that
just started off on a [ __ ] sex tape
yeah and look at the next yeah but
you're still looking at at the daily
slice of life who have what happens in
30 years they knew how to manage money
though so they would probe wealthy to
wealthy so it's and that's Hurley you
know that's her lane if that makes her
happy [ __ ] it yeah [ __ ] [ __ ]
I'm just saying there's nothing to envy
cuz she look like trash yep
got a nice teeth no yes welcome Eve did
I [ __ ] you B you guys are all savages
she does know how to play the game and
all these other social media people's
cuz when our friend
Bradley Martin opened his new gym in
Woodland Hills she showed up and I was
like wait what do you have to do with
fitness I don't know but I guess people
that are like very buzzy stay in the
buzzes
there's always like buzzing each other
up until they stay as it was that's what
we got but we're not good at buzzing
cash bout ha ha ha
[Music]